(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] A man is at a restaurant.
The waiter is like, "Hey, we have a great
sea bass tonight."
"Shut up," the man says.
"I would like a juice glass with water,
a lemon wedge and a match."
The waiter is like, "What?
Okay, you weirdo."
The man pours the water onto the plate.
He's like, "If you can get this water
into this glass without touching or moving
this here plate, I will
give you a 100 dollar tip,
one hundo dollar ruskies."
That night the waiter walked
home 100 dollars richer.
How did he do it?
- Em.
- You have to be some kind of sorcerer,
some kind of magician or god.
- (sighs)
- If my junior high science
class taught me anything,
I think I might remember how
to do something like this.
- I think like the lemon is for the water
after he drinks, he's gonna drink it.
The water and he wants
lemon for the water.
- I like 100 percent have to light
this lemon wedge on fire I think.
- Fuck you wedge.
- That's what I feel right?
Yeah, it kind of feel,
I just can't figure out.
- I just need to keep the
air inside, inside here
so I'm guessing I just
need to, interesting.
- There's gotta be a way.
- Are you supposed to light the match?
Does the fire help?
- Feel like it's just the surface tension
on the, on the water,
not on the heat inside.
- Did I get it right?
- Kind of.
- This is bologna (chuckling).
- [Voiceover] So, what's the right answer?
Well, first the waiter put the lemon
in the center of the plate,
then he lit the match and
stuck it in the lemon.
Then he placed the glass upside
over the lemon.
As the match's flame used
up the oxygen in the glass,
it created a vacuum
which sucked in the water
where the glass met the plate.
So the waiter was able to
get the water into the glass
without moving the plate.
Hey, stop that.
("Bada Doop")